hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game that was played yesterday
between hikaru nakamura and dalireza
ferugia it comes as a suggestion from
daniel bargio so thank you for
suggesting such a
wild game they had a match and this is
one of the games they're
they've played it's a three-minute blizz
game so three minutes plus zero seconds
increment
and it's uh well it's a great game and
it's a really funny game
especially because nakamura thought that
he had something
and then he realized he didn't but
actually he he did
so it's really weird uh but it it is
very enjoyable but before we check out
the game i would just like to mention
yesterday was my birthday
uh so i decided to throw in a nice
tournament unleashes on saturday so
the link will be in the description
below everyone is welcome to join
i set a price fund to 1000 uh however if
any of you guys want to contribute to
the to the price fund
100 of all the contributions will be
added to the price fund so
all the info is in the description below
if you guys are interested in joining in
i will be streaming all of the games so
as usual there's a chance that your game
will be showcased uh uh while you're uh
delivering some very deadly attacks and
achieving
great victories now that being said uh
let's check out this game so nakamura
has the white pieces and he opens with
e4 alireza goes for c5 the sicilian
defense and hikaru goes for d
for the smith mora gambit uh and uh
on the stream he said that he he maybe
alireza
isn't um as great in playing this line
as
he should be so he's gonna he's gonna
try it he doesn't uh
think much of it but it could work so c
captures on e4 and now
c3 uh you know continuing in in the
style of this gambit
but alireza does not capture on c3 he
plays knight to f6 so he declines the
gambit goes for the alpine formation
uh with e5 by hikaru knight to d5 and
now queen captures on d4 with e6 now
defending the knight and knight to f3 uh
knight the c6 attacking the queen now
queen to e4 and here
alireza goes for f5 he wants um ahikar
to play he captures an f6 alpha
and then both of the knights will be
excellently placed and he will have
a very very strong central setup so here
we have queen back to e2 by hikaru and
queen to c7 now
uh we have g3 preparing to fiance to the
light square bishop also hikar wants the
castle
and now b5 here oh it is a spend a few
seconds on this move but it's a it's a
very tricky move actually if the pawn is
accepted
then uh you play a5 and now you're
threatening bishop to a6 and this is a
well an ugly position for white even if
you go all the way back
it's still very ugly you're just going
to play a4 and now
how does black how does white castle
here if you prepare castle and then
bishop to a6
and you're not castling here knight c4
you can play knight say f5 again
if you castle then just bishop captures
on c4 it's a very very ugly position for
white
so instead after b5 we have bishop to g2
right away by hikaru
and now bishop to e7 continuing
development we have castles and
now a5 so continuing the expansion on
the queen side
uh we have rook to e1 and now comes the
bishop to a6
there's now that the beef not that the
rook has been played on e1 the b
pawn uh was maybe even uh capturable
but now okay bishop to a6 uh we have a3
now
uh and just castles by ali we have queen
to d1 hikaru doesn't like his position
here all that much uh
b4 is coming at any point so you don't
want your queen on e2 he plays queen
back to d1
and now bishop back to b7 elireza also
wants to counter
uh hikaru strong light square bishop on
g2 so here
knight b to d2 preparing either knight
b3 or maybe knight f1 to e3
and now a4 so just grabbing more space
on the queen side preventing
hikaru from gaining any active squares
knights to f1
and now knight to b6 with the idea of
maybe going to c4
so here we have knight the e3 and now
knight to a5 so now this knight can come
to b3 this net can come to c4 it's going
to be very hard for for hikaru to play
this
we have knight to d4 and now as the
bishop is under attack here we just
traded bishop captures king captures but
not king captures because if king
captures then queen captures an e5 is
coming
you don't have any good discoveries and
the queen covers the b5 square so you
can't win your pawn back
so here hikaru has to play knight
captures on g2
and now queen to b7 uh so what do you
play here
we have knight back to e3 and now comes
knight beat the c4 offering a trade of
knights hikaru trades once we have
captures captures and
now queen to e2 so now there is some
pressure on this b5 pawn the e51 is
nicely defended uh so
what can alerza play here he plays rook
a to c8 he continues development
uh and h4 now uh hikar wants the
wants to get this bishop at the f4 and
he doesn't want to allow
moves like g5 could be very nasty so
here rook the c5 violet is
now with a double attack on the e5 pawn
and now bishop to f4 defending this
we have rook to d5 and now comes rook 8
to d1
and now hikaru finished the development
of his pieces uh
and uh alireza has to figure out how to
how to get through this so he goes
bishop to c5
and now comes knight back to f3 and here
alireza could capture on b2 but it's a
very tricky line uh
if knight captures on b2 we're going to
capture with the queen
and now rook captures on d1 rook
captures queen captures on f3 and now
rook captures on d7 so here
black can be very happy as black's
bishop is much much better than white's
bishop here
on f4 however alireza decides to capture
on d1 first uh we
rook captures on d1 and only now knight
captures on b2
uh and now it's a it's a bit different
because now hikaru doesn't have to
capture now hikaru could play rook to b1
and it's uh well it's it's a very tricky
position bishop captures an a3 black is
still better
but he he allowed him this option uh but
hikaru continued with queen captures on
b2 and now we basically continue in the
same line
uh queen captures an f3 rook captures on
d7 and now
h6 creating some breeding room for the
king here
and now queen to d2 uh here if you go
after the b5 pawn this is
super dangerous as you're getting mated
just queen captures here
king h1 and queen to g1 will be
checkmate so instead after uh this h6
move we have queen to d2 he car
likes his position here very much
there's a double attack on the h6
pawn the rook is very strong on the
seventh rank uh so here alireza played
rook to c8 and here he allowed hikaru to
end the game on the spot uh so feel free
to pause the video here and try to find
this incredible idea that alireza missed
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those who were able to do it
congratulations on
sacrificing the first thing that popped
into your head and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it's a rook
cactus and g7
that's that's the good stuff uh and now
if you don't accept
this it's just for example bishop
captures you ruined black's entire king
side
and black doesn't really have any any
threats at the moment so
it's just a winning position for white
so black's only hope is to capture the
rook
but now now comes queen d7 check and now
if you go up the board then we can pick
up the rook with check so king to g6
now queen captures an e6 with check king
the h7
queen the d7 check king g6 and now h5
check this is the move you had to find
uh and now uh the problem is uh well
if you capture with the king then just
queen capture sun f5 is checkmate
so you have to capture with the queen
and this is crucial so now you don't
have queen captures on f2 so only now
you pick up the rook here
and here white is just winning if you
try and uh you know
start something here with queen back to
f3 then we just go for a check mating
attack queen g8 check king h5
queen to e8 check the king doesn't have
all that many squares you have to go to
g4
now queen g6 check king to h3 and now
queen captures an h6 check
and now that's it you either go king to
g4 then queen to h4 is checkmate or you
block with the queen and then
we deliver this checkmate i i prefer
this one so we're gonna leave this one
on the board so queen the h
h4 checkmate so this was in the position
however
after uh alireza's rook the c8 he carl
played
rook back to d3 he attacked his queen uh
and now he says uh well okay let's uh
let's give him the f2 pawn
and alireza goes for it here this is
very dangerous and this
there's no need to do this queen to e4
is or queen to b7 is what you should
play
queen bishop captures an f2 was played
but now this makes it
much easier for hikaru so now king to h2
and now queen to e4 now getting the
queen out of harm's way and now if queen
captures then queen captures on d3
so now hikaru repeats rook to d7 uh and
alireza now just goes back uh the bishop
here is under attack so bishop back to
c5
but now hikaru can grab on g7 but it's
not as potent as a few moves ago
so rook captures on g7 was played king
captures on g7
queen to d7 with check and king the g6
now
and here it's very funny because here
hikaru played queen captures on e6
king the h5 uh and now uh hikaru is
again winning you have to go for a
repetition here
if you don't want to get checkmated uh
so here
uh like i said after queen captures on
on e6 uh
played king h5 and hikaru said oh my oh
man something like uh i
i i didn't think he had this i thought i
would be checkmating him
uh but he in fact is checkmating him he
just doesn't know it so
feel free to pause the video here and
win the game for the second time for
hikaru
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on
not playing uh queen captures on h6
although it looks
so great it simply doesn't work and for
those of you who found the g4
congratulations as this is the only move
that wins
problem is if you go for this queen
captures here king g4 queen g5 check
king of three
even queen to h5 with check king f2
uh there are no more moves uh it's just
gonna be queen to g2 checkmate and
there's nothing you can do
uh to prevent this so what you had to do
here after
king to h5 is g4 with check and now the
problem is
if f captures then you block the king's
escape there's no g4 square for the king
and then queen captures an h6's
checkmate
so you couldn't capture with the pawn
you'd have to capture with the king
but it's not much better just queen to
g6 with
check king to f3 we're gonna play queen
to g2 with check
king captures on f4 and now queen to g3
will be checkmate
so really really incredible stuff what
uh what
uh you know uh what uh what uh hidden
paths
uh this game is hiding so here after
king to h5
we have queen to f7 check hikaru misses
g4
here so queen f7 checked but now alireza
gets to escape with his king
king to g4 we have queen to g6 with
czech king to f3 queen h5 check king of
two
and here uh for the lack of a better
move hikaru grabbed the pawn on h6 but
now alireza just
delivered queen to g2 checkmate and we
get to this
awesome formation that on this channel
we we call the chess threesome and it's
been a while since uh since we had this
so really really uh really awesome game
hikaru uh was right he
could outplay alireza in the in the
elephant variation
he had one chance then he had the second
chance but it's
it's uh pretty crazy because i mean
hikaru is so strong in for example
puzzle rush he sold everything
uh but in puzzle rush you know there's a
solution when you when you're playing a
game you don't know that there's a
solution and you know
it's uh i guess it's important to treat
every position like there's a solution
but
it's a three-minute blitz game you don't
have all the time in the world so
uh you know if you if you spent uh all
that much time on every position you
would very quickly run out of time so
it's um
uh you know a nice mixture of both
so yeah that's the game i hope you guys
enjoyed it like i said if you're
interested in joining in
uh on saturday do check it out the link
is in the description below so you can
join the tournament it's
you know it should be a lot of fun uh
i'm not planning on any guests
i'm probably uh going to be streaming
alone but you never know
you know what could happen uh and also i
just wanted to share this with you guys
the champions chess tour is continuing
and we have the return of a very strong
chess player ho yifan
uh is returning uh to the board uh or in
this case uh you know uh
over the over the uh computer and she's
gonna be joining
these uh fine gentlemen uh in the
pursuit for for winning uh
win winning the tournament so it should
be a lot of fun i'm very very interested
to see how how she will do after
after uh being away from the board for
for
for such a long time uh but yeah once
again i hope you guys enjoyed it really
a crazy game
i would like to thank mr hoody guy david
young andra lazaroy
nelson edwards and rafael lenz for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon
uh continuing the morphe saga checking
up on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day